and everything's really difficult right
when you control everything you don't
care about money I mean I'd like to
actually argue we talk about Bud Light
this Melanie whatever is it whatever
yeah
yeah Dylan Mulvane sweetheart yeah
and yeah I know we've damaged their
share price Etc et cetera I would
believe people who own that company or
beyond that company I don't think they
truly give
in both I don't think they can
I don't think they're losing that much
sleep over it maybe they are a little
bit but I'm saying you get to degrees of
power and levels of power where you
don't care about money I'll give you a
perfect example of it I know we keep
going back to this but it was actually a
massive pivotal event in Awakening so
many people was the Covenant scam
I said this multiple times in many
different countries I visited I said if
they cared about you they would have
left everything open maybe put a tax on
everything
extra tax percent whatever and Bill
hospitals why didn't they do that why'd
they why did they lock you all up
because it's a mass Appliance exercise
they want you to comply they don't get
health they just want you to comply they
want to test how many people comply
and people were saying yeah it's all
about money it's all about profit and I
said that's actually a very optimistic
way to look at it I think that if you
destroy the economy and lock everyone in
their houses and Destroy everyone's
businesses you don't care about money
you're you're beyond money you're above
money you want power and you want
control
because once you become actually rich
you learn that the world is all just
about people
right the best things in your life for
people best things in your life for
family things make you happiest are your
friends your life experience is the best
if you have good news good assistance
checking Instagram
what do you want money for it's the best
thing in life with friends
I want Lamborghini I can't build one he
can I will pay him to build me a
Lamborghini it's all about people so
once you get Beyond a certain level of
money
and there's a certain level of control
you want that money perhaps can't buy
buy then you think well I don't care
about the money I want the power
I want money I want them to stay in
their houses why because I said so I
don't have to they have to haha it's
funny and that said and sat with people
and said do you really think people in
charge of the world are so petty that
they would lock everyone in their houses
so they can laugh and say yeah I
actually do I think if you were born
into a wealthy family where money has
precisely zero value and you are
arrogant to the Moon because you're this
whoever and you believe you're God's
gift and you don't a Ferrari ain't gonna
make you happy you can throw a Ferrari
Ferrari's freeze pennies you don't care
about any of this [__] what makes you
happy is everyone respecting you and
being afraid of you
to a degree you're going to try and
influence some power on fear I think
that's what it is so I think a lot of
these companies when they're doing these
things and they're upsetting people Etc
yeah it's good that we're fighting back
but I also think part of them enjoy the
show
I think part of them genuinely enjoy the
show I think part of them go you know
what
let's do this is this is insane let's do
this oh they're fighting uh I really
believe it I I know it's a pessimistic
way to look at it but I think they enjoy
the show apart I don't disagree with you
in in regards to that I can see that how
you know you see it in movies or scenes
where you know condescending arrogant
you know and they kind of want to they
enjoy bullying the guy that can't help
himself right hey do this hey clean I
pick this up ah look at this he'll do
anything that I need him to do right I
fully believe those types of things
exist but man empires have fallen so
many times because they thought they can
get away with murder and then eventually
people said listen stop you're not gonna
do this to me anymore we're not we're
not going to take a stand and typically
when that happens you said it earlier uh
you know what is really why what's going
on in Glendale or some of these other
cities that people are protesting why is
there an organization called gays
against groomers gays against groomers
what what do you what are you doing and
I just wanted to be given leave me alone
I'm not trying to be you know grooming
kids that's not my job I just want to be
gay leave me alone we've made so much
progress these guys I'm not that guy I'm
not this person right so I think the
part that
they fear the most if you read Communist
Manifesto there's a book written by uh
Cleon skousen I think he was like a
former CIA agent for like 15 years he
wrote a book called The Naked communist
one of the things he talks about how
getting rid of God well they're
succeeding in that area but not fully
yet you know getting rid of the family
nucleus well we already know what is the
purpose of this lgbtq movement what is
the purpose of this transgender what is
the purpose of let me get this straight
this person cannot buy a gun at 13. this
person cannot go in the military at 13.
this person cannot vote at 18. this
person cannot own a car at 13 but they
can transition the most the most
important decision of their lives you're
okay with yes now that doesn't make
sense to me that doesn't make sense to
me I think you said something at the
beginning the the concept of being
tolerant you know what yeah it's okay we
can't have gays oh it's okay we can have
this so uh listen man uh-uh you've
crossed the line I think Faith Family
Kids values principles they fear the
hell out of absolutely and I think that
Community is rising up no you're totally
right but you made a really interesting
point there where Empire is falling and
this is where I kind of feel like we're
entering a new stage of the world
because it's never really done before
because typically when Empires fell the
world was far more polarized if the
empire fell there was nowhere for the
corrupt dictators of set Empire to go
the Empire's Fallen where I say let's
say England fell you can't it's very
hard to get Exile in France you could do
it a little bit but let's say America
fell today let's say it completely
collapsed and it fell the people who
archetyped that downfall do you think
they beat America
do you think they'd be sitting there
waiting to get scooped up do you know
who they are
can you recognize them what's their name
even if you could do you think they're
in America or do you think they're
skiing is so sad
this globalism the whole point of
globalism is that they don't care when
Empires fall when you globalize the
world then you have a chess board I lost
the knife it doesn't matter pulpation
sack the queen who cares there's so many
things I want to say that I don't want
to die but there's truth this can be
proven and shown even with this current
proxy war
Europe and all the gas prices and the
inflation rate in Europe has gone to the
Moon to fund this proxy war in Ukraine
why does this happen because America's
in charge of everything and America has
decided that Europe has to Bear the
brunt of the [__] for its proxy war
you're going to have higher gas prices
you're going to have inflation you're
going to have massive unrest you're
going to deal with it all right and
we're going to sit over here and
insulate ourselves because we have the
global Reserve currency and the war is
going to happen over there and
everyone's going to die and we're in
charge
so now we have this globalism how can an
Empire fall when you have basically two
camps there's two teams now there's two
sides left so it's it's a it's I agree
with you completely about Empire is
falling but I'm saying if the empires
fell in days of old the Kings would be
strung up
but now when the Empire Falls nobody
knows this doesn't matter we don't know
who the kings are we don't know who's in
charge we don't know where they are
they're not going to be anywhere near
the trouble that's for [__] sure
there's gonna be somewhere else oops oh
well and do they really care
do the people in charge of the world
care if America's crime rate goes up one
thousand percent would they lose sleep I
actually think they do partially
because think about it so I'm with
Andrew Schultz and I'm taking your
position with him yeah okay you know
what Andrew Schultz is good guy and he
says you know part of me that gives me
Comfort is no one these guys are so
obsessed with their money he may be
wrong so we can debate this they're so
obsessed with their money that there's
no way they're going to let America fall
because if America Falls everything else
Falls so they're going to go just as
much as they can to control but not
enough to get the machine to break
because they're so in love with money
and power they don't want to give that
up well I hope that's true I would love
for that to be true but my argument is
that these people are already so deeply
entrenched they print the money
go print the new money I don't care they
cared about money covered wouldn't have
happened they closed the entire economy
I don't think they care about money I
think they can I think they control the
world to a level where you want to eat
do you want war
like I I don't think they give a [__]
about money they'll print the new money
they'll change the name of it and print
the new one a certain level of power I
think they're so above and beyond all of
our concepts of how the world works and
they don't have any interest in any of
it I don't think they give a [__] I
think if you were to go to these people
whoever they are and say we're going to
take your money away they would just
laugh at you you think you can take my
money you think you understand money you
think you're going to damage the stock
market you think I give a [__] about
share price
I think there's a level beyond all of
this and they're the ones who truly are
running things and they truly have no
influence and in fact the harder they
damage the economy and the more damage
they do to money the more people are
dependent on governments to eat that
sort of Communism comes from right the
more poor we get the more you need the
government just so you have food in your
mouth how can you resist the government
if they feed you
you can't
so yeah like and I sound pessimistic and
I'm not pessimistic and I do believe the
answer to all of these things is free
thinking and truth and God and Community
standing up for themselves and changing
the general consensus I do believe that
because to a degree
although we talk about people who run
the world to a degree We Run the World
because
our tolerance level is what runs the
world there's more of us than them so
two degree you say who's in charge of
the world well I like to say what we are
because it's all about we're the Abu
we're the abused wife in this
relationship how much crap are we gonna
put up with we set the limit they're
going to come at us with everything they
can right we set the limit but the
problem is they try very very hard to
one increase our limit to the max which
is tolerance and two to divide us to the
point where we don't ever unite long
enough I love what happened in Glendale
what you just told me about that should
be happening in every single School
Across America all of them oh they would
love it if you retweet the video for
them and give more exposure I will do
you know it's when you're saying this
I'm reading a book right now Robert
Moses I don't know if you know who he is
or not power broker it's a guy it would
be very interesting guy for you to study
this is the guy that built New York okay
and he came up and uh uh hate it
a complicated person misunderstood uh
the more they would push him back the
more he stood up the more they would say
no this is not fair what you're doing
the more he would even say I'm gonna go
more even more extreme
and so if in New York you mentioned the
name Robert Moses there's going to be a
camp that's going to say scumbag racist
white supremacists all this stuff and
there's a side that's going to say this
guy built a bridge this guy did this
this guy did that he he he would make it
so hard for a certain Community go to
the nicer Community he would put the car
you know the bridge so low that trucks
couldn't go through because he didn't
want the bad people to go into this like
he was that sharp and one time in the
book they talk about how Robert Moses he
says look the one thing about Robert
Moses he could give a [__] about money
he could give a [__] it was all about
his influence over so I agree there are
certain people that don't care about
money they're more driven by control
influence all of that the part that uh
you know we're talking about the movie
Fury Vinnie and you give me this whole
thing about Fury the scene where Shia
LaBeouf is reading out of the Bible and
he's crying while he's reading this and
then right if you want to text me what's
with the and then afterwards you see
Brad Pitt quotes exactly what scripture
it was but they never showed how much
Faith he had and the whole point was I'm
ready to die we know we're here this is
going to be happening we're in detectors
don't I think the people
there's a part about Trump uh how to
grow on Whitney Webb I don't know if you
know who Whitney Webb is we had to run
okay yeah and we start talking about
different things and I've been having a
lot of weird guests on lately
and making a comparison between the
Kennedy family and Trump
pisses a lot of people off but those two
families forget the fact that one's a
Democrat one's a republican they were
both anti-establishments they were both
anti-military industrial complex they
were both anti-cia anti-fbi anti-all of
this stuff right we saw what happened
with Kennedy we saw what happened with
Reagan we saw what happened with Lincoln
all these guys were anti-establishment
guys we saw what happened with Trump the
part about Trump that
you know
made the other side uncomfortable it's
okay we can kill the guy
that's been the strategy for a long time
you can't really do it today
as much because they fear one thing that
they're the most jealous and envy you
know what that is they don't want they
do not want to build a martyr yes they
fear building a martyr because that's
the ultimate high that they want to get
they do not want to build a martyr right
so okay we're going to humiliate the
crap out of you we can embarrass the
crap out of you we're going to publicly
try to do this we're going to come in
between you and your kids you know we're
going to go get your daughter to be more
LGBT we're going to get her to be on
this side and we're going to pin this
that's the strategy we're going to put
the break into our family apart right
and he still stands up there yeah
and and to them it's like what the hell
do we need to do yeah freedom is you
know just sit down and be quiet not
willing to do it that's right do you
think again going back to it
more of those types of men and women who
are misunderstood and complicated
stories they they're not perfect far
from it more of those guys are the ones
that are saying yeah it's just not going
to happen on my Watchmen and that's what
we need and the the by the very nature
of being the kind of person who's
principled enough to risk his own
personal
situation in life if you have principles
that strong you're going to be disliked
by some people you're never going to
have a person who is principled enough
to take risk to his public detriment for
the good of what he believes in who's
liked by everybody that that's a logic
fail right because he has principles
which are hard lines and people exist
across the entire Spectrum so there's
many people exist outside of those lines
that's what I liked about Trump he's not
perfect of course not but he says what
he means he means what he says I
actually disagree with them on many
things but he says what he means he
means what he says and that's what
they're afraid of they're afraid of a
man who says what he means and means
what he says because he can't be bald
because he's principled he can't be bald
even now me if they're in a country with
100 million dollars and say We'll
respond to you with this company's 100
million dollars you just have to shut up
I'd say no I don't want your money I
don't want the money I don't need money
there's nothing else to buy I bought
everything I don't need it I buy
principles worth more so and that's what
they're afraid of they're afraid of
principles and it goes back to the
original point they're trying to remove
all of our morality all of our Baseline
understanding of things my neck is an
application which allows you to take a
minute to connect with influencers from
all around the world my name is Andrew
Tate and I'm available to speak directly
to you on minute that's that's how they
inject you with the slave mind that's
exactly it is and you're right history
has always been that way and now it's
under conscious assault
I've never said this before I've never
even thought this before this is a brand
new thought for me but I would like to
think in times of old in history perhaps
everybody was the same everybody was
principal everybody had parameters but
they were different parameters perhaps
there were competing ideas but I think
in the modern world it's not so much
competing parameters it's just people
who believe in things people who don't
believe in anything besides what they're
[__] told and it changes every day do
you have the empty brains
the the slave minds and the people who
actually stand up for something
but the slave Minds you can't say well
they believe in a different ideology
because they don't they believe in what
they're told to believe in on that
particular day it changes they don't
have any true core belief they just
repeat
I talk about the Matrix all the time and
people say why did you choose that
terminology and I chose that terminology
because it's perfectly accurate in
describing exactly what is happening The
Matrix is a computer program which is
designed to control your mind so that
your body can be used to power the
machines that's exactly what happens
when they make you watch the news to
control your minds you continue to use
your body to work some garbage job and
suffer from inflation and power the
machines machines being soulless people
who are in charge of the world but
there's also a million other different
ways you can compare the Matrix to the
real world and the Matrix they say
anybody can become an agent at any time
if their mind is not unplugged they
become an agent if their mind is not
free they turn into an agent you can see
that in real life mention kova to an NPC
mention Trump to an NPC you can sit and
have a perfectly cordial normal
conversation with somebody for an hour
be fine and you can mention one of the
particular subjects which they are
programmed to Hate by The Matrix itself
and they will turn into an agent in real
time and you will see them now start to
genuinely emotionally dislike you as a
person they were your friend for an hour
yeah now they hate you they will turn
into an agent Kobe was perfect I would
sit with people we'd all be friends
until I mentioned the code's garbage
oh
now they're an agent what do you mean
Kobe's garbage my friend's grandma was
99 she got sick
okay sorry
it doesn't change my view
and they change and and the Matrix is
actually a perfect absolute explanation
of what's happening and and Morpheus
says it if your mind's not freed you can
be one of them and that's what's
happening and this is why we have we
don't have competing sets of parameters
which you're trying to argue about which
is the best way to run the world we have
people with parameters who believe in
family and love and God and tradition
and taking care of yourself and taking
care of others there's people with moral
standard and there's people with none
zero empty vessels agents who are
programmed on any given day of whether
what they're supposed to care about
these people can't tell me they care
about things that's what's most annoying
about my position because it's
absolutely an hourly weaponized virtue
they use against me the people who hate
me hate me because one I I truly believe
and I know this is arrogant to say but I
feel like I have to say it there's huge
there's definitely a massive jealousy
implement
if I wasn't so tall and rich and good
looking wouldn't be happening they don't
[__] like me they don't like me
because I remind them of the joke at
school that took their girl that that's
part of it right they don't like me
personally so they can't they try it
it's true so they try and find an attack
vector and what happens when you have
somebody who's monumentally successful
across all Realms of human endeavor the
only way you can attack them is by
calling them a bad person they can't
call me stupid they can't call me ugly
can't call me broke can't call me weak
they can't go into these things so how
do you attack this guy well he's a bad
person how do you call someone a bad
person you weaponize virtue none of the
people not who are pretending to give a
[__] about women
and that I'm bad to protect women have
any interest in protecting women none of
these people think I better become
physically strong so protect women none
of them even believe in protecting a
woman in a physical scenario I don't
even believe in protecting their family
let them have any oh God
wait none of them donate to any
Charities that involve women nothing
they're just taking the virtue and
weaponizing it and attacking me with it
me as a person who donates 25 million
dollars a year to charity to feed both
male and female children me as a person
who believes I have a responsibility to
be physically capable so that any woman
I'm walking down the street with is safe
I do more for women than any of these
clowns and this is the crazy thing it's
always the people that do are doing
nothing
it's like even when I got in trouble for
the you know you know what kind of
contracts they accuse me of given
it was all these people that had zero
contracts that did nothing and it's
always the people that do nothing I
think MLD is muted um but it's always
the people that do nothing but that are
the most that are doing something but
it's like well why don't you go do what
we do yeah yeah no it's true because
that because that's just like what
valueless people do I talked about
earlier in a live stream I was doing
today it's people who cannot provide
value what they do instinctively is tear
others down exactly you know you're
either in this life either somebody who
adds value
or you're someone that destroys value
and these people they've like and the
majority of people are
that the type of people that can't add
value that's why they watch these fake
news reaction channels right because
those guys are losers and what do these
losers do they attract the loser
audience and then they create this loser
[__] system that's going on and like
you know every time I got I got attacked
by you know a a blue-haired feminist
recently and uh his entire Army attacked
me it was so funny everybody was like
insult to me I would click on their
profile photo it would be some fat loser
or some ugly whale or some like you know
some soy looking dude earlier do like a
million piercings in his face like
criticizing me and I'm just like wow
this is hilarious because the thing is
this too the good will always be
outnumbered by the evil right and the
smart will always be outnumbered by the
stupid but
because we're smart because we're good
we have an advantage over them you know
their own stupidity works against them
but it's that's they I think part of it
too is like a certain hatred for
themselves because they know that they
can't provide value so they try to tear
us down you know what I mean because
look at us so we have all the resources
in the world to go out and tear people
down but we don't even our platform is
not built upon tearing people down it's
a it's built upon lifting people up but
they want to take like one little spot
of our imperfection human existence and
try to tear down our entire message but
be like oh look at this one little thing
you did incorrectly therefore everything
you've said is incorrect no and and
that's the thing it's like a lot of
these guys have been on the internet for
a minute where they could have
reinvested into organizations they could
have reinvested into people they could
have built something big and none of
them did it where where it's like a lot
of them have been successful for a long
time and it's I was thinking as a guy
I'm like
Imagine The Pinnacle of your existence
the Legacy you've brought to the world
is a drama Channel dude it's such loser
done even like the guys that stream like
10 hours a day and I'm not talking with
real people just like online 10 hours a
day for without doing anything else for
years it's like what does that do to
your I know I go a bit too crazy even
doing the shows like if I don't leave
here enough I'm like I go a little bit
nuts yeah yeah I'm like I can't imagine
doing that for years and years and years
what that would do and you can like you
can like see the negativity like build
on them even like I mean you know like I
I used to not always be the biggest fan
of my red and then I came around and
realized like they're doing such good
things for men oh yeah and you can see
like they get better and better and all
of their critics and detractors like
they get into better shape their critics
and detractors get get fatter they get
like more like down like they have crazy
weird relations you know that's why
Myron's so bulletproof in these debates
because it's just like literally like
years of like putting hoes in their
place like no [__] this is why you're
wrong and here's he's like you know he
could you could wake Marin up out of a
drunken stupor and have him like debate
five feminists at once and he'd knock
them all out you know no he's gotten so
good he's really good the sauce cast
like um or the thing they did at sauce
he was amazing that was like one of his
best debate performances ever mine's a
beast man he's seriously like you know
as a guy who
like practices what he preaches I mean a
lot of people behind the scenes don't
really understand how disciplined and
like by the book Byron really is and
he's just so bulletproof in all he says
because he has everything that backs it
up and sure like is everything he said
a hundred percent solution for every
woman on the planet no there are certain
situations where he's not correct but at
the same time you know for the majority
of the situations he is correct and
that's what he's trying to do we're not
trying to be perfect we're trying to
give a large enough solution to help as
many people as possible with a generic
advice you know what I mean yeah and
that's that's the thing though like it
really irritates me because they'll like
dig into you guys and be like oh well
there's this one example of when he
sipped or there's this this one time
where they dated a single mother like or
what like whatever whatever their like
gotcha moment is yeah but it's it's just
like okay is what they're saying true I
don't even care I don't even care if
like they're the biggest simp on the
planet I just want to know like is what
he is saying correct you know and that's
funny Destiny is so dumb like he played
right into my hand because I asked him
what are his thoughts about money
muscles game frame completely agreed
with me
not a single rebuttal nothing along
those lines agreed with everything I
said what is that the muscle it's just
it's the thing that I tell guys you
gotta make money make muscles learn game
and hold frame this is the core four
things a man should be working on which
is basically make money learn how to
make money learn how to manage your
money learn how to invest money don't be
a guy that's in your 30s or even late
20s when your money is still a problem
for you make muscles which is basically
don't be fat take care of your physical
fitness that's the most important thing
you have on this planet learn game
understand what is attractive to women
what is unattractive how to attract
women bring them into your life how to
know which a good woman is versus what a
bad woman is so you have sexual access
so you're not like sexually starved
because a lot of these guys sell their
dignity just to get some [__] and then
frame is about your self-esteem
boundaries your perspective on life what
you want in life what you don't want and
enforcing those boundaries and what I
mean by enforcing them is basically
identifying people who do not agree with
with your life statement who do not
agree with your boundaries and simply
removing them from your life and never
letting them back in and I say focus on
those core things money muscles game
frame and the detractors to this day
have nothing to say nothing to go
against that to be fair money is not
necessarily super important but being
able to manage it brings stability yeah
that's good I agree with you but think
about this too like when the check comes
everybody looks at the man everybody
looks at the dad you know when even
before if us if us for we're gonna go
out to dinner right me you and then
blessing right
um I'll definitely look at you you made
a million a month so well no no I'm just
talking about the people and we're
ordering when they order yes the staff
is going to look at one of us and be
like all right man who's paying up you
know they're not like hey ladies like
you're you're the best yeah you know
even though Pearl's balling and you're
the [__] director of 900 companies
you know what I mean you know they're
gonna ask them they're gonna look at the
men because the onus is on men
traditionally speaking and even today
you know when women are looking for a
guy you know these high value women
they're looking for guy that got their
[__] together because they don't want to
pay either it's just how it's part of
being a man and then you know the also
in addition to that all people are
pretty [__] with money all people are
pretty stupid like so it's a skill you
should absolutely work on mastering so
you can be above average individual but
again like when they try to attack our
message they can't they say like Pearl's
a grifter or Pearl's this or Pearl's hat
but a lot of people who hate on Pearl in
the Internet space reality is they're
just jealous because Pearl built a
[__] Empire in like a like what less
than two years is is two years now a
year and a half right a year and a half
year and a half crushing the game right
doing it with a smile on her face not a
bitter bone in her body and they're just
jealous a lot of these people are
massively jealous
and so that's what they do they try to
attack Pearl as an individual say oh
you're grifter you're not married you're
this you're that whatever trash excuse
because that's all those excuses are
they are not valid they're not trash and
they can't attack the bulletproof
positions that she has taken of course
you know what everything she's saying is
backed up with hard science when these
other [__] want to be like oh
well you should destroy a relationship
over Choice really really chores like
are you are you are you [__] infant
everybody already said he's like you're
such a child and I'm
he's like he'll they'll be like oh
you've never had a real relationship and
then do a hit piece on my ex-boyfriend
I'm like which one is it yeah I just
want to know choose your Insanity you
know he's calling you a child he's 34
years old dying his hair blue
he's like oh and then I'm like What's
the alternative you've had all of these
failed relationships yeah it's like it's
like abandoning your son for a [__]
wait no did that I didn't know that
happened I'm just leaving it Sunday I
could go chase this horror across
[__] Europe you know what I mean so
when you're looking at all these things
I didn't know that happened yeah yeah
he's a kid he's a kid
um but United divorced her left and all
just so he can go run his gay [__]
fantasy across Europe with his yellow
two four so the reality is uh like
they're trying to like paint us as bad
people then when we live a better life
we live a more pure and clean life and
we're better role models for society
than they are you know what I mean and
they and then they do what liberals do
they just do like this hyper
manipulative
explanation that you have to like sit
down and like really dig into the
details like you know you really doesn't
work out this way because if this person
is you know black lives matter supporter
and they're then they hate Trump and
then they're trans transgender and then
this and this and this and like this
like crazy hyper Nuance example they
give you is supposed to refute all of
the positive work that you've done do
you know what they did to me um this
pissed me off because this was so
intellectually dishonest so I did um I
did a show with Destiny right and on the
show he you know it's crazy I was like
we were so nice to him we took him out
to dinner
I was the same way I was nice as [__] to
the guy but it was like a week later I
see him on stream talking so much [__]
about me I'm like oh wow wow I was like
Jesus which you know it's like one thing
if you've never met but I was like I was
actually really nice to him but you know
what whatever but snake but it was crazy
because we were on um the the couch and
he corrected me because I said that like
women are fatter than men and then he
corrected me that said that and he said
they weren't but then I went back
because I was like wow that doesn't seem
right
but what happened is they include the
fat not just the OB stats so it makes
men look fatter but it's like if a guy's
in jacked that still goes into like the
um BMI correct BMI just isn't a really
good way to measure it and when I looked
at things that that are supposed to be
more accurate I forgot what it's called
but it's like hit to waste ratio men
versus women and obesity stats because
that's a bit like you you're more obese
women than they're obese men right and
so album preached in this whole video
calling me off of course they did they
called me a liar and they called him two
on the chores one uh because I they I
they gave one study that said the
opposite of what I said but it was funny
because their study was it was
um started they they criticized me for
using one study then they used one study
and theirs was by a woman who she she
majored in like gender studies or
something so it's like very obvious her
agenda did a chores one and then it was
funny for the
yeah for the obese one they said I was a
liar and the crazy thing was I corrected
it in the comments I gave them the link
and they then they um they like edited
their comments so they weren't calling
me a liar anymore like with these grown
ass they're so old they're like look and
they look like 40 I don't know how old
they are but they look like they're like
they're like in their late yeah so
here's the thing right if they're so
Superior they're so smart and their way
of living is so
above what we're calling for right why
is society trending towards their filthy
way of living and everybody's [__]
miserable yeah and we're and we're
straying away from traditional stuff and
everybody was happier before and and
Society was way more functioning way
more stable way more healthier I mean
you got so many people are afflicted
with mental health disease nowadays it
is absolutely
detrimental to the Western population
and it's because we've been straying
away from the values that built this
great nation the way it is and we keep
on doing it and it keeps on getting
worse but they're just like no let's
just like let's keep going down this
path you know we just need more
diversity we need more inclusion we need
more all these Buzz Words which are
really just eroding away at the
foundation of society while China and
Russia laugh at us as they keep it
traditional over there yeah India too
like like people are sleeping on India
and China I mean dude those are the
future Global powers of course well and
it's like what are women really happy
without children no we're not and it's
funny like I never thought about not
going to college but that's the opposite
of like
um because you know they always they
never really talk about like the white
community's problem you know they never
even look at us as a community but I was
like
but I was like it's really common for
like white women it's like we'll go to
college
um and it's like we're very like
achievement oriented and that's you know
it's not a bad thing but it's like I
didn't realize that when you go to
college
um it's like an inverse relationship to
having children
and I I didn't realize that yep yeah it
makes sense absolutely because think
about it right you know the thing is the
when you look again at female happiness
in the United States of America
every single year they set new lows like
literally since like I think they
started documenting it in the 70s and
every year women are becoming less and
less and less happy as they all got
tricked into being consumerism slaves
right and then they just don't they're
they're being bombarded like I said it's
it sucks for women because you know you
have the media you have the government
you have social media you have movies
you have mainstream music you have video
games all saying you go girl get out
there and be a boss babe get out there
being CEO guess what you all you all
can't be CEOs but you know what you all
could be you all could be a mother
those mother positions are not running
out anytime soon same thing with wives
you have a better chance to have a wife
and mother life than you do have to be
CEO and they just think you're going to
be CEO and like yeah I'm CEO and I work
four hours a week and like this is great
dude like how many hours a week do you
work Pearl I don't know a lot like more
than 40 right probably yeah I mean it's
it's hard because
it's like do you count tweeting you know
yeah I mean no but yeah but you're on
the clock like you're you're working I
mean your tweet from the moment you
[__] wake up yeah I'm a tweeter you
know big Tweeter but that's the thing
you know when I when I graduated um
College
um I really just decided I was like you
know I I see the like party lifestyle
and I was just like I just don't want to
go down that path and I made like a
conscious effort to like stop drinking
and like not really go out and just like
stay away from that lifestyle and it
it's interesting because a lot of my
friends I went to school with they're
like overweight you know they're in
these like
crazy relation you know and it's just
like
it and me I'm like thinner than I was
when I graduated you know so it's it's
just like you can go down the path of
just doing whatever you want but it the
grass isn't always greener on the other
side no the grass is greener where you
water it yeah you know 100 so I mean
again going back to these people I mean
really these people are just the Bottom
Feeders of society and they're making
this low hanging fruit content which is
just basically like if you look at all
these people they they they're just
continuously just [__] on one person
to the other person that's all they do
yeah their legacy is tearing people down
and honestly if the joke is on them
because that that [__] with you as an
individual if you're gonna be that kind
of person go around tearing people down
tearing people down eventually it's
going to catch up with you you can't go
through life just souring a bunch of
humans and expecting great Triumph
success the majority of people who have
exceeded to succeed at high levels they
have done this through cooperating
working together Building Bridges
building alliances not tearing other
people down not making your life's work
to cause people emotional harm emotional
stress and financial troubles as many of
you know I was just banned
band and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible